des poubelles incendiées volontairement
dans les quartiers faites votes et des
prébendes à Tours plusieurs rues ont été
prises pour cibles ce week-end dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche notamment les
rues de Metz du général Cavaignac
François Cluzel Miquel de l'espérance et
de la prévôté des feux de poubelles qui
se sont propagées résultats pas de
blessés mais 13 voitures détruites ou
endommagées et également des dégâts à
déplorer sur les façades de plusieurs
maisons le ou les auteurs sont toujours
recherchés reportage de Romain Delville
avec Benjamin Vatel
cet habitant de la rue Miquel devait
partir en vacances dimanche matin
vacances repoussées plein de contre X au
commissariat ce propriétaire de
véhicules incendiés dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche doit aussi payer les
frais de remorquage
du matin mon épouse qui me réveillait me
dit chérie j'ai un problème et un
problème dehors
regarde-toi
elle a insisté j'ai ouvert la fenêtre
jusqu'à l'automne première étage au
total ce sont 13 véhicules qui ont été
incendiés dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche et quelques poubelles il semble
que l'incendiaire est mis le feu à des
poubelles ceux qui s'est propagé aux
voitures comme ici rue du Cluzel ou six
véhicules ont brûlé
depuis son salon une habitante a filmé
ses images qui témoignent de la violence
des flammes j'ai vu les flammes à
travers la porte j'ai ouvert la porte en
espérant pouvoir faire quelque chose
mais j'ai vu que c'était trop tard il y
avait déjà deux voitures qui étaient en
train de brûler donc j'ai refermé la
porte j'ai appelé les pompiers les
pompiers m'ont dit que ils étaient déjà
prévenus ils allaient venir qu'il
fallait bien rester enfermé dans la
maison
l'enquête dirigée par la police de Tours
devra déterminer si une ou plusieurs
personnes sont responsables de ces
incendies volontaires ainsi que le
parcours du ou des incendiaires